Shawn is in Lexington Kentucky hi Shawn
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thanks
for taking my call Dave sure how can I
help yes I was calling to find out what
is a good starter stock to invest in how
much should I bet okay
I don't invest in single stocks they're
too much risk they go up and down and
sideways and it's even the people that
supposedly know what they're doing lose
their butts doing that instead I invest
in good growth stock mutual funds which
a mutual fund would have 90 to 200
different stocks in it that way if one
of them goes sideways the rest of them
are no hopefully doing okay and you come
out ahead that if you spread your money
across several things instead of putting
it in one thing that's called
diversification and it gives you safety
do you see what I'm talking about yeah
you know so I I invest in good growth
stock mutual funds now it's in stocks in
growth stock mutual funds but the stock
selection in those funds is done by the
fund manager and you can look at that
fund and say the guy or gal or group of
people picking that stock their stocks
in this thing have pick stocks that have
given me a rate of return of 14 percent
average for the last 22 years and I can
go oh well that's pretty good fun I
think I'll buy that one that would be an
example okay and you can find mutual
funds that have averaged 10 to 12
percent somewhere in there in the last
long periods of time 20 years 30 years
that kind of thing so you're looking at
their track record and that's the type
of thing I invest in I don't own any
single stocks I don't go buy such a such
a company and then try to figure out by
Friday if it's a good idea and jump back
out of it I don't fool with all that the
people that I meet that are wealthy the
majority of them are slow and steady
they're the tortoise they're not the
hare hare runs around all over the place
looks cool and gets nothing
loses the slow and steady ugly tortoise
that everybody makes fun of is the one
that wins the race every time I read the
book and that's how investing works and
that's how you'll want to do it if you
need some help with that Shawn jump on
Dave Ramsey dot-com and click smart vest
and because you're getting ready to be a
smart investor and that put in your
information and drop down a list of the
people we recommend in your area I'm not
in that business but we have people that
we recommend and they're called smart
Wester pros and one of them will be
happy to sit down and begin teaching you
so that you learn and you do it because
you understand it not because dave said
to or somebody else said to